ever get the feeling you're being
watched if you're out for a stroll on
the farm you might be right
that's because sheep and their sweet
woolly faced lambs have a secret like
people these farm animals have
specialized neurons that focus on faces
and they remember those faces for years
researchers think our brains process
faces not as a collection of features
but as integrated holes for which we
extract the information from - or 3d
representations to find out if sheep can
recognize faces in this way
researchers train them to recognize
photos of celebrities the sheep had to
choose between the celebrity and either
a blank screen and object or an unknown
person all the Sheep passed the test
scoring an average of 80% showing that
they can learn to recognize unfamiliar
faces even in 2d but are the Sheep
memorizing the images or do they
recognize individuals in a second test
sheep had to choose between a
celebrity's face shown at a different
angle in an unfamiliar person humans can
do this but our accuracy drops from
around 90% to 76% turns out there was no
pulling the wool over these ovine eyes
the Sheep passed a test with a drop in
performance similar to people that means
that sheep like humans and other
primates seem to have advanced face
recognition abilities something to keep
in mind the next time you come face to
muzzle with one of these
gazing grazers
[Music]
you